it was the deadliest european conflict
since the second world war
a hundred thousand people killed more
than two million displaced
nationalism that led to ethnic cleansing
sexual violence and genocide
a brutal conflict that tore bosnia apart
the bosnian war ended nearly three
decades ago but many of the underlying
issues that led to it are now
re-emerging the solution of
bosnia-herzegovina will happen
if the situation in this state continues
like this so could we really see another
war break out here
[Music]
the story of bosnia is complex but it's
vital to our understanding of what's
happening here today
bosnia is made up of three main ethnic
groups bosniaks who are mostly muslims
bosnian serbs
and bosnian croats
now an important thing to remember is
that these groups are separate from
serbs in serbia or croats in croatia but
they do have close ties and a shared
history
after the breakup of yugoslavia in the
early 1990s nationalism started to rise
in the now independent nations this led
to issues in each of those states as
well as wars in croatia and slovenia but
bosnia was particularly complicated due
to its multi-ethnic makeup many of the
bosnian serbs wanted to be part of
serbia
many of the bosnian croats
wanted to be part of croatia
the bosnian serbs were led by this man
radovan karadic
he threatened violence if bosnia were to
become independent
and then in early 1992
the un
did recognize bosnia and herzegovina as
an independent nation after a referendum
and fighting julie broke out
it was
a difficult complicated conflict with
all sides battling each other but the
bulk of the conflict was between the
serbs and the bosniaks
it was a particularly horrible war
bitter brutal and bloody with
mass rapes massacres and the first use
of the term ethnic cleansing the bosnian
serbs backed by the serbian president
slobodan milosevic took over huge parts
of bosnia
they forced tens of thousands of bosniak
muslims and croats out of their homes
in mass ethnic cleansing
thousands and thousands died
mostly bosniaks
the capital of bosnia sarajevo was
bombarded daily in one of the longest
military sieges in modern history and
here in srebrenica bosnian serb forces
under the commander raccoon lavish
[Music]
8 000 bosniak men and boys it was the
worst massacre in europe since the
holocaust
shahida's husband and brother were both
killed her teenage son escaped death by
fleeing into the woods
foreign
the war finally came to an end in 1995
with the dayton accords
[Applause]
dividing up bosnia into two autonomous
regions the federation of bosnia and
herzegovina
and the serb controlled republica
serpska
dayton implemented a complicated
political system in the country to
introduce power sharing it relies on
nations such as the us and the european
union to maintain the peace
bosnia even has a three-pronged
presidency that rotates every eight
months between a serb a croat and a
bosniak
the dayton accords did bring a shaky
peace to bosnia but after three and a
half years of bloodshed people here were
divided and traumatized
now some of those old wounds are
beginning to open 30 years later bosnia
is once again caught in a complex
volatile dispute that embraces ethnic
divisions and religious rivalry
[Music]
[Applause]
and this man miller dodec is at the
heart of it
he is the serb member of bosnia's
rotating three-pronged presidency he's
also a former prime minister and former
president of republika srpska
he's an ultra-nationalist he's
threatened to take republica serpska out
of bosnia and herzegovina he also
downplays the genocide at srebrenica and
speaks of his admiration for the russian
president vladimir putin
the
sort of
nationalist views that he has are more
or less common amongst all serb
political parties all major serve
political parties he does not
uh in any way think that compromise is
possible uh and in a country a
multinational country such as boston
herzegovina compromise is the key aspect
to moving forward in any sort of policy
direction
if this is not a possibility as
miloradox says then the only other
possibility is for the country to break
up which is clearly on his agenda and
donick is not some curious outlier in
fact many share his views
the butcher of bosnia is a hero to many
and nationalists like dodic and pavlovic
want to see republika serpska run its
own affairs and raise its own army they
also claim serbs in bosnia are being
marginalized by the bosniaks
talk like this all seems depressingly
familiar
but a new aspect to this equation is the
role of russia
we have a very very strong historical
relations with the russians
and we believe in russians
personally i love russians
more than americans putin is admired by
nationalists here he and doric have a
strong relationship
russia is also close to serbia an
obvious ally to the bosnian serbs who
are just over the border and many in the
west fear russia is trying to find new
ways to undermine european unity
from a russian perspective another
european war
might distract from ukraine stretch nato
and challenge the status quo
and bosnia with all its divisions and
its volatility
could be the perfect candidate
so could this actually escalate into
another war
it all depends on how much presence the
international community is willing to
have in the country
throughout the past 10 years or so
there's been very little
investments from the european union from
the united states from nato from
basically any international actor
in trying to
keep bosnian politics in line and we
have seen this escalation as a result of
this
so what you do have is a country that
does not really want
war as such but wants to resolve
conflict in other ways
and this ability to resolve conflict in
other ways it's not there and you're
you're stuck in a way that
you want to move forward but not with
the current leaders because they're not
willing to do so
sarajevo is now not too different from
other modern european capitals far
from the war-torn besieged city of the
1990s
and there does seem to be little desire
for another war across both regions of
bosnia a 2021 survey found that 45
percent of residents of republica serbs
are actually against independence from
bosnia 35
say they support that idea
72 percent of the people responding said
that avoiding inter-ethnic violence was
the most pressing issue in the country
but some who lived through the previous
war
do fear a return
[Music]
[Music]
the dayton accords created a piece that
has lasted a long time
but bosnia remains a divided and hurt
country
and the trauma that many hoped to leave
in the past could soon be brought
kicking and screaming
into the present day